385 million years ago, fish had fingers.
Half of all human beings have mites living
in their eyelashes.
The average Internet user goes online 34 times
a day.
The cast of Riverdance have worn out 14,000
pairs of shoes.
Cruise ships have morgues on board.
Roughly 200 people die on cruises each year,
most deaths are due to old age.
So most ships have small morgues that can
store up to 10 bodies.
The design for the Guy Fawkes mask, commonly
worn by anonymous protestors fighting against
government and corporate corruption, is owned
by Time Warner.
Ironically Time Warner gets a percentage of
the profits every time one of the masks is
sold.
In response to a question from a 5 year old,
the Royal Mail has calculated that it would
cost £11,602.25 to send a letter to Mars.
The floods in Australia in 2010 and 2011 caused
the world's sea levels to drop by seven millimetres.
For 87 years, the Portuguese kept the existence
of Ascension Island completely secret from
the rest of the world.
If the Earth had no clouds, the sea would
completely evaporate.
In 19th-century Britain, prisoners were let
out for the day if they paid a fee of £5.
Roughly £300 in today's money.
Human beings had been keeping sheep for 7,000
years before it occurred to anyone to use
their wool.
If everyone washed their hands properly with
soap, it would save 600,000 lives a year.
During its lifetime, the International Space
Station will be hit by 100,000 meteoroids.
In World War II, many German soldiers used
steroids to make themselves more aggressive.
The first motor insurance policy issued by
Lloyd's of London described the car as a 'ship
navigating on land'.